on va le faire de manière responsable
sur la base d'un budget équilibré et ça
commence avec des budgets équilibrés
le chef néo-démocrate le martèle depuis
le début de la campagne électorale son
parti va équilibrer le budget coûte que
coûte
vérifications faites à la lumière de son
cadre financier dévoilé aujourd'hui ça
va être un exercice périlleux
le npd utilisent les prévisions
économiques du budget conservateur
déposé en avril pour établir ses propres
budgets des quatre années suivantes des
prévisions trop optimistes de l'avis du
directeur parlementaire du budget des
grandes banques canadiennes et de l'
ocde qui ont revu à la baisse ses
prévisions de croissance économique
les grandes banques canadiennes ont
dressé un tableau est encore plus sombre
avec un taux de croissance d'au moins un
demi point plus faible que prévu chaque
point de moins représente une baisse de
4 milliards de dollars en revenus pour
le gouvernement fédéral dans le dernier
budget conservateur on prévoyait aussi
un baril de pétrole à 70 dollars en 2016
les experts par maintenant d'un prix
sous les 50 dollars
ces deux incohérences priveront les
coffres de l'état de plusieurs milliards
de dollars par année et surplus annuel
de 3 à 4 milliards prévus par les
néo-démocrates pourraient ainsi se
transformer en déficit
tout un défi quand il prévoit une
augmentation des dépenses de 11
milliards de dollars d'ici 4 à pour
financer entre autres leur vaste
programme universel de garderie le npd
compte aussi sur une hausse de deux
points de pourcentage de l'impôt des
sociétés
pour augmenter ses revenus de plus de
trois milliards et demi de dollars or
certains économistes disent que cette
mesure pourrait entraîner la perte de
150 mille emplois ici des martin chabot
radio canada montréal